Tomaten sind eines der hungrigsten Gemüse
im ganzen Gemüsegarten und eine Frage habt
ihr mir immer wieder gestellt in den letzten
Wochen nämlich, wie zum Teufel dünge ich
meine Tomaten so, dass sie mit allem versorgt
sind, was sie brauchen?
Darum soll es heute gehen, ich werde euch
erzählen, welche Nährstoffe Tomaten überhaupt
brauchen und warum.
Wie ihr erkennt, ob eure Tomaten Hunger haben,
also ob sie eine Portion Dünger gebrauchen
könnten und wann ihr welchen Dünger verwendet
und wie ihr erkennt, ob ihr zu viel gedüngt
habt.
Also bleibt bis zum Ende mit dabei, es wird
auf jeden Fall spannend.
Viel Spaß mit dem heutigen Video!
Falls du mich noch nicht kennst, ich bin Marie,
ich studiere ökologische Landwirtschaft und
baue das Obst und Gemüse für meine Familie
fast komplett selber an und die Erfahrungen,
die wir dabei gesammelt haben und weiter sammeln,
man lernt ja nie aus, die gebe ich hier auf
dem YouTube-Kanal an euch weiter und auch
in meinen Kursen.
Ich freue mich sehr, wenn ich eure Tomatenfreundin
sein darf dieses Jahr., wir haben ganz viele
Tomatenvideos geplant.
Und wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert, also
wenn ihr wollte, dass ich euch das ganze Jahr
über mit den Tipps versorge, die ihr braucht,
damit eure Tomaten zu neuen Höchstleistungen
auflaufen, dann abonniert gerne den Kanal.
Es kommen, wie gesagt, regelmäßig bis in
den Spätsommer hinein, immer wieder Tomatenvideos
hier auf dem Kanal.
Ja, jedes Gemüse hat ja so ein bisschen einen
unterschiedlichen Geschmack, was die Nährstoffe
angeht.
Tomaten stehen vor allem auf fünf Sachen,
die wollen sie gerne in der Erde haben, mit
denen wollen sie gerne versorgt sein.
Der wichtigste Pflanzennährstoff für alle
Starkzehrer, zu denen Tomaten ja zählen,
ist natürlich Stickstoff.
Stickstoff ist für das Massenwachstum zuständig,
dafür, dass die schön in die Höhe wachsen
können, für das Blattwachstum, das ist also
eine Komponente, die Tomaten in großer Menge
brauchen.
Dann brauchen Tomaten auch Phosphor, das ist
vor allem wichtig, damit sie schön viele
Wurzeln bilden können und auch Blüten bilden
können, aus denen ja später die Früchte
entstehen.
Und das Kalium, was sie brauchen, ihr habt
es euch wahrscheinlich schon gedacht, NPK,
sind sehr wichtige Nährstoffe für Tomaten,
das Kalium ist dann dafür da, dass die Früchte
sich richtig schön bilden können, dass die
auch ausreifen.
Das sind also drei wichtige Stoffe, auf die
ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon selber gekommen
seid.
Dann gibt es aber auch noch zwei Stoffe, die
nicht so offensichtlich sind, das ist einmal
Schwefel und das ist einmal Magnesium.
Da habe ich euch ja schon in meinem letzten
Video, wo wir Tomaten gepflanzt haben, oder
in meinen letzten beiden Tomatenpflanzvideos
gezeigt, dass ich da immer Magnesiumsulfat
mit ins Pflanzloch gebe, sodass die Tomaten
mit Magnesium und Schwefel, Magnesiumsulfat
enthält Magnesium und Schwefel, gut versorgt
sind.
Das ist also ein super Tipp und seit ich das
mache, geht es meinen Tomaten wirklich viel,
viel besser.
Dann kommen wir zu drei unterschiedlichen
Arten der Düngung, die man durchführen kann
bei den Tomaten.
Das ist einmal die Grunddüngung, von der
ich ja auch gerade gesprochen habe, die Düngung,
die man den Tomaten bei der Pflanzung mit
ins Pflanzloch gibt oder die man vor der Pflanzung
in den Boden einarbeitet, da gebe ich ja gerne
Hornspäne, Magnesiumsulfat und Urgesteinsmehl
in gleichen Teilen mit ins Pflanzloch, da
mische ich mir immer dann diese geheime Düngermixtur
zusammen.
Wenn euch das interessiert, schaut gerne nochmal
das Video zum Tomatenpflanzen an, da zeige
ich euch das ganz genau.
Das ist die Grunddüngung, die habt ihr ja
aber wahrscheinlich schon gemacht, denn jetzt
sind die Tomaten ja in der Regel schon in
der Erde.
Und jetzt wird eine andere Form der Düngung
interessant, gerade, weil wir ja in das Pflanzloch
Hornspäne gegeben haben, die sich erstmal
umsetzen müssen im Boden, bevor sie den Pflanzen
überhaupt zur Verfügung stehen.
Hornspäne sind zwar ein super Tomatendünger,
aber die haben einen Nachteil.
Es dauert ungefähr sechs Wochen, bis die
überhaupt anfangen, pflanzenverfügbar zu
werden, weil die Pflanzen die Hornspäne nicht
sofort aufessen können, sondern die müssen
erst durch Mikroorganismen umgewandelt werden
in pflanzenverfügbare Nährstoffe und das
dauert seine Zeit, sodass die Pflanzen, wenn
du sie mit dieser Grunddüngung gedüngt hast,
noch nicht sofort mit den Nährstoffen versorgt
sind, die sie eigentlich brauchen.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass wir die Tomaten
während der Saison immer wieder mit regelmäßigen
Düngergaben unterstützen und ihnen noch
schneller verfügbaren Dünger in Form einer
Flüssigdüngung über das Gießwasser zur
Verfügung stellen.
Das ist dann also die regelmäßige Düngung.
Das kannst du so ungefähr alle vier Wochen
machen, je nachdem, wie die Tomaten aussehen.
Man sieht ihnen das schon an, wenn sie Stickstoffmangel
haben, das zeige ich euch gleich noch, ich
habe hier so ein paar Tomaten, die nicht ganz
so gut aussehen glücklicherweise für dieses
Video, sodass ich euch das gleich demonstrieren
kann.
Aber es ist eben ganz wichtig, dass man dann
regelmäßig den Sommer über, direkt nach
dem Pflanzen kann man da anfangen, noch diese
Flüssigdüngermischung mit dazugibt.
Dafür könnt ihr entweder einen fertigen
Tomatendünger nehmen, bitte einen Bio-Dünger,
das ist wirklich ganz wichtig, also mir zumindest
ist das sehr wichtig, dass man darauf achtet,
dass das kein chemischer Dünger ist.
Da kann ich euch gerne mal einen Dünger,
mit dem ich gute Erfahrungen gemacht habe,
unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinken,
den ich euch gerne empfehlen kann.
Ich kann euch gerne alle Sachen, die ich hier
erwähne einfach als Link noch in die Videobeschreibung
packen, sodass ihr da schauen könnt, was
ich verwende.
Ein anderer toller Dünger, den man sogar
selber machen kann, ist Brennesseljauche.
Da kann ich euch auch gerne mal eine Anleitung
filmen, wenn euch das interessiert, wie man
Brennesseljauche herstellt.
Alle, die in meinem Gemüsegarten-starten-Kurs
mit dabei sind, wissen das natürlich.
Also schaut da nochmal rein, da habt ihr die
Anleitung, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, damit könnt ihr eure Tomaten also sehr
gut regelmäßig düngen, wie gesagt, alle
drei bis vier Wochen.
Ich würde aber nicht unbedingt jedes Mal
Brennesseljauche verwenden, sondern ab und
zu auch einen biologischen Tomatendünger
oder Vinasse verwenden.
Vinasse ist auch ein super toller Tomatendünger,
das wird aus Zuckerrohr hergestellt, ist auch
ein biologischer Dünger, den ich super gerne
an meinen Tomaten verwende, weil das wirklich
einen richtigen Stickstoffschub gibt.
Also es gibt wenige biologische Dünger, die
so stark düngen wie Vinasse, das grenzt schon
an die Wirkung von mineralischen Düngern,
ist wirklich ein krasses Zeug.
Passt auf eure Hände auf, wenn ihr das verwendet,
ich habe eben meine Tomaten damit gedüngt
und hatte sofort einen ganz klebrigen/ Hier,
hier, da kriegt man dann diese braunen Flecken
und das klebt dann alles voll.
Aber ich liebe Vinasse, das ist wirklich ein
saucooles Zeug, das verlinke ich euch auch
in der Videobeschreibung.
Also entweder Brennesseljauche alle drei bis
vier Wochen geben oder einen biologischen
Tomatendünger, der genau auf die Bedürfnisse
der Tomaten abgestimmt ist oder Vinasse, auch
ein ganz cooles Zeug.
Und da am besten, wenn es euch möglich ist,
immer ein bisschen abwechseln, weil Brennesseljauche
jetzt nicht unbedingt alle Nährstoffe in
der Menge enthält, die Tomaten brauchen,
sodass es ganz gut ist, einen der beiden anderen
Dünger zwischendurch auch nochmal zu verwenden.
Und die dritte Form der Düngung ist die Notfalldüngung.
Da könnt ihr, wenn irgendetwas Ungewöhnliches
mit euren Tomaten passiert, wenn die irgendwelche
komischen Blätter bekommen, Flecken bekommen,
dann könnt ihr in einer Liste, die ich euch
gerne hier unter dem Video verlinke, mal nachschauen,
was das denn sein könnte.
Das sind ja oft Schädlinge, Krankheiten oder
Nährstoffmangel.
Und dann könnt ihr gucken, haben eure Tomaten
vielleicht einen Kalziummangel?
Und dann dementsprechend gezielt diesen Stoff,
der euren Tomaten fehlt, nachdüngen.
Also ich habe euch da eine Liste unten verlinkt,
die ist auf meinem Blog, da könnt ihr schauen,
nach den Symptomen ist das immer gegliedert,
was euren Tomaten fehlt.
Ich habe da ganz viele Tomatenprobleme aufgelistet,
sodass da hoffentlich das dabei ist, was bei
euch gerade schiefläuft.
Da könnt ihr gerne reinschauen, wenn irgendetwas
Ungewöhnliches an euren Tomaten auftritt.
Ja, wie macht sich denn bemerkbar, ob man
jetzt zu viel düngt?
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Erst mal, wenn ihr euch überlegt, wie viel
soll ich denn düngen, schaut einmal auf die
Packung des Düngers, den ihr verwendet, ich
kann euch da jetzt keine allgemeingültigen
Rezepte an die Hand geben, weil ich ja nicht
weiß, wie eurer Dünger dosiert ist, aber
da steht normalerweise immer mit drauf, wie
man den an den Tomaten anwendet.
Dann, wie gesagt, einfach mit ins Gießwasser
geben und die Tomaten damit düngen.
Und wenn ihr merkt, dass eure Tomaten ganz,
ganz dunkelgrüne, fast schon schwarze Blätter
bekommen, dann ist das ein Zeichen dafür,
dass ihr es vielleicht ein bisschen zu gut
gemeint habt und die Pflanzen überdüngt
habt.
Jetzt sprechen wir nochmal, wie man denn erkennt,
ob sie vielleicht unterdüngt sind?
Also ob eure Tomaten vielleicht ein bisschen
hungrig sind.
Dafür gehen wir einmal da rüber, kommt einmal
mit.
Da gibt es ein ganz gutes Erkennungszeichen,
zumindest, was den Stickstoffmangel angeht,
was ja der häufigste Mangel ist, weil das
der wichtigste Pflanzennährstoff für eure
Tomaten ist, und das sind gelbe Blätter.
Und ich habe hier bei meinen Freilandtomaten,
die ein bisschen zu lange in ihren Töpfen
ausharren mussten, das perfekte Beispiel.
Da sind nämlich jetzt schon die unteren Blätter
gelb gefärbt und daran seht ihr, dass die
Pflanzen Stickstoff brauchen.
Die fangen immer in den unteren Blättern
an, den Stickstoff zu entziehen, um ihn dann
in die oberen, neueren Blätter reinzupumpen.
So machen die Pflanzen das, die unteren Blätter
sind die am wenigsten wichtigen Blätter,
deswegen müssen die als erstes dran glauben.
Und da erkennt ihr dann relativ bald schon,
ob euren Pflanzen Dünger fehlt.
In dem Fall hier mit meinen Freilandtomaten,
die jetzt wirklich schon sehr gelbe untere
Blätter haben, teilweise sind auch die mittleren
Blätter schon relativ gelb, würde ich jetzt
als erstes eine Vinasse anrühren, also die
Vinasse mit in das Gießwasser geben.
Da müsst ihr einfach mal auf die Packung
schauen, wie da die Dosierung ist, je nachdem,
was für ein Produkt ihr euch da anschafft.
Weil die sagen ganz, ganz, deutlich, dass
sie Hunger haben und dass sie jetzt dringend
Dünger brauchen.
Das ist auch nicht so schlimm, wenn das mal
vorkommt.
Also da müsst ihr euch keine Sorgen machen,
wenn die Pflanzen mal einen Mangel anzeigen,
einfach schnell reagieren, schnell nachdüngen
und dann erholen die sich wieder und wachsen
fröhlich und munter weiter.
Wenn ihr noch mehr Fragen habt rund um die
Tomate, irgendwelche Probleme, die euch belasten,
irgendwelche Fragen auch rund um die Selbstversorgung,
um den Gemüsegarten, dann schreibt mir das
gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich sammle gerade Ideen für neue Videos,
da bin ich auf jeden Fall sehr gespannt, was
ihr euch so wünscht.
Ich will ja die Videos machen, die euch am
besten weiterhelfen, also helft mit bitte
mit Ideen, ich freue mich auf jeden Fall auf
euch.
Übrigens, falls ihr das noch nicht wusstet,
ich bin immer samstags zwischen 10 Uhr und
11 Uhr hier auf YouTube online und beantworte
eure Fragen unten in den Kommentaren.
Das muss auch gar nicht um das Thema gehen,
worum es in dem Video geht.
Dann kommt gerne da dazu, das ist immer eine
ganz nette Plauderstunde, da freue ich mich
immer schon jede Woche drauf, da mit euch
einen bisschen direkteren Austausch zu haben.
Ich versuche natürlich auch unter der Woche
immer einmal Kommentare zu beantworten, aber
wir haben ja jetzt schon hier dreißigtausend
Abonnenten, was übrigens richtig cool ist
und da schaffe ich es nicht, alle Fragen zu
beantworten.
Aber wenn euch irgendwas auf der Seele brennt,
wenn ihr irgendwelche ganz dringenden Fragen
habt, dann kommt immer samstags mit dazu.
Oder wenn ihr einfach nur ein paar nette Worte
mit mir wechseln wollt oder mit den anderen
Leuten, die da zuschauen.
Das ist unglaublich, das ist eine Blattlaus,
oder, die mir da gerade über das Gesicht
krabbelt?
Vielleicht mache ich bald einmal ein Video
über Blattläuse.
Ja, wenn euch das interessiert, schreibt es
in die Kommentare. wenn euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und wenn euch das weitergeholfen
hat, dann gebt ihm gerne einen Daumen nach
oben, da freue ich mich wirklich ungemein
drüber.
Das ist auch etwas, das wusste ich, bevor
ich mit YouTube angefangen habe überhaupt
nicht, dass das einem YouTube Kanal wirklich
so weiterhilft, wenn man da diese Däumchen
nach oben bekommt.
Also da bin ich immer sehr dankbar dafür,
danke für alle, die es immer schon machen.
Ja, und ich werde mich jetzt von den Blattläusen
befreien und sage tschüss, bis nächste Woche.